the seven deadly sin sequel called four
nights of the Apocalypse has an anime
and it's actually airing right now a lot
of people don't know this but the four
nights anime has been airing in Japan
for the past 3 months it hasn't been
released in the west yet because
freaking Netflix owned the rights and
they usually like to release an entire
season of anime at once instead of
airing them weekly so unless you like to
sail the high seas you might not even
realize that the seven deadly sin sequel
already has an anime thankfully the four
nights of the Apocalypse anime is
finally coming to Netflix January 31st
2024 so you'll be able to watch it even
if you're not sailing the grand line at
first the sequel follows a new character
called peral but soon we'll see familiar
faces from the original Seven Deadly
Sins including Lancelot Tristan motus
gother Arthur and many more for all the
latest 7 Deadly Sins sequel updates
subscribe to anime uproar right now